and so this is joint work with
krishnendu charity who is at iast
austria wife can't wash aku sits over
there in boro iqaluit some power okay so
i'm going to first teach you some new
problems and then tell you what you know
about this no problems okay so first
I'll tell you about new problems that
actually come from model checking
just perfect doesn't seem to work okay
okay this pointer works okay and so
assume you want to design a no system
and how do people usually go around it
first the more organized people the
first write down a formal specification
and then they might want to have this
specification checked whether it has any
problems box okay other people are more
sort of let's go to it so they first
write the program they implement
something and then they have a program
that might have might be correct or not
they are sure so then they build an
abstract model modeling the program and
then again they might want to have this
checked the result of the model checker
can be that it says okay we have not
found any bugs where can be to say there
are these and these problems and then
there's a feedback loop and they might
just then the program or the
specification or even the system design
so now we want to talk about this part
here what algorithmic problems arise in
the model checker
okay now there are multiple models the
people use and never introduced the
first two and which always are the
easiest ones it's always the easiest
ones and so one is simply directed
graphs so the node in this graph would
be a state of the system you can think
of the state of a system is the value of
all possible variables in your program
for example in the edges in the system
or as follows if there is a way to have
a transition from one state to the other
state you insert an edge for example if
the program adds a value to a variable
then you go from one state to the other
state okay good so that's the simplest
thing however very often there are some
inputs from the outside world and so
there might be system transitions that
are not caused by your program because
there's some input from the outside
world for example you gets might get
some experimental data from the outside
world where you might have some messages
come in and these messages might come in
over some lost channel so there is some
random noise it it comes with this kind
of information or you might also have
some randomized protocols now you're not
sure who succeeded in doing something
okay so they these kind of uncertain
situations usually are modeled by
introducing specific types to notes so
our graph will now become a Markov
decision process very simply by saying
nodes of two types either they are the
first type these are the nodes that we
know and love from graphs the standard
nodes or be a random notes and every
random node has a probability
distribution on the outgoing edges
associated with it and for the purpose
of this talk you can't just assume that
this is a uniform distribution even
though it doesn't have to end it all
works fine if it's arbitrary
distribution as long as every Edge has a
nonzero probability truly constant
probability i should say okay so this is
obvious analyze ation of grass and then
there are more complicated models which
i'm not going to get into here
now what do we want to do on these
things well we want to generate infinite
paths on either graphs or MVPs and
people do this as follows and he plays a
total at the start node to assume you'll
give more as a start node we will place
a token on the start node and this totem
will now get moved over the edges as
follows if the token is currently at a
random node then you pick the outer edge
according to the distribution for that
node now you know remember we train the
node we have a distribution the outer
edges and if the total ok so let's do
that and if the token is at the player
one out ah it works then the algorithm
gets to choose which outage ok player
one which will be the algorithm gets to
choose which outage ok so now you can
move things around ok in this crap
forever and now look at all the places
that the top visited that will give you
an infinite paths ok now let amiga be
the set of all possible infinite paths
induced on the way in this way on the
macros decision process or on the graph
okay so now I've told you of models i've
told you infinite graph pass now i want
to tell you about what do we want to
compute on these graphs and that's what
people are model checking call
objectives ok so what our objectives
that's what we want to compute and so
objective is always a subset of the set
of infinite paths and one very simple
objective is a you and you're usually
given some set to you some subset of the
nodes in the graph and our MVP and so
very simple objective is just reach of T
reach of T is the set of all nodes that
visit an arbitrary node of tea at least
once all the set of all this path for
example vice is interesting then assume
each vertex actually actually represents
the state of I processes is larger than
one and they all want to use some shared
resource and then some tea might be the
set of states that represent the
situations where each process has used
the resource at least once and so if you
want to check is it true that every
process will reuse the research ed at
least once you want to check whether
actually with your algorithm it's true
that reach of T is fulfilled all the
infinite paths that are generated by
your algorithm actually will visit a
note in T at least one now the dual
problem of reaches safety and dual means
and if you take a set Omega of all
possible paths you take outreach in
what's left over is called safety of T
now safety of T are all the paths they'd
never visit a vertex of tea and that's
interesting because you see if the SEC
teased all the bad states you want to be
sure that you never get to a spin state
so that's the first the most tempest
objectives are these tour and now let's
do it let's go to a little bit more
sophisticated objectives so the next one
is called boo she also called pookie for
people who can't pronounce PG and I keep
on going back and forth excuse me
because I keep on working with people
who can't pronounce it so they say
bookies or I said poppy but then I talk
to my hospital says the suspicion
so I tried to stick with Russia okay so
bougie and so these are all paths that
we city infinitely often okay and that
seems like a good idea like if T is the
set of states where process is a good
shape you know you know no problem so
far you want to get there infinitely
often make appreciating the duel so
that's all the past that visit only
finitely off okay and so now you know
four objectives so now we have models
grab the NDP's we have objectives now
what do we want to do so there will be
three types of algorithmic questions and
I'll go again from simples to the most
complicated one the first type is the
decision version and the decision
version is as follows assume you for a
graph you give them a start node is
there an infinite paths that satisfies
the objective objective you're given a
fixed objectively curry to save to your
book lyoko pookie and is there an
infinite paths that satisfied so for
example for reach of tea it would be
very simple is there a path from the
start node to a vertex in tea and by the
way this is infinite paths you might say
what if I cannot generate infinite an
infinite paths but if there is a node
with no outage but we get rid of it we
only want to have graphs more MVP's
where every node has at least one outage
okay so it could also be a self loop
self loops are ok too okay but in this
way we can always have internet pass
okay and so if you have a pass from the
start node to vertex NT just go to this
vertex in T and then from there on there
must be some infinite paths it doesn't
matter take any arbitrary one that will
generate an infinite paths and that
visits t at least once for beauty you
can this problem is equivalent to saying
Kane the start vertex reach strongly
connected component that contains a
vertex NT because if you get to a
strongly connected component that
contains a vertex NT in there you can
visit this node in t infinity often
the MVPs and the question is as follows
given the start node is their strategy
for player one that ensures that the
objective is satisfied with probability
1 now let me define what I mean so
strategy strategy and I'll give you a
bit of a simplified version you have a
strategy strategy is just a function
from a note to the neighboring note okay
so a strategy is a decision that player
1 makes it says whenever I met this note
I will take this outage now in reality
reality being for more complicated
objectives you actually need a little
bit more complicated strategies because
the way here I define the strategy is
every time when the token comes to the
fixed node and the player one that has
fixed the strategy has to take the same
outage and for more complete this is
fine for the simple objectives for more
complicated objectives you can actually
show that the strategy also has to
depend on the history on the path that
you have taken so far to get to this
node and so depending on different
histories to get to this node there
might be different outages that the
player might want to take but you can
prove for the simple objectives that
I've talked about so far they exist a
strategy muah sophisticated strategy
that looks at the history if and only if
they exist one of these simple
strategies which means is actually fine
the player can always take the same edge
at the same note so a strategy is a
decision that the player makes that
whenever he gets the note he takes a
certain outage and now the question is
can you ensure that the objective is
satisfied with probability 1 so what
does that mean look for example at this
entity this is a random note history
outages and now what is the probability
that an infinite paths gets to this node
at least once well it's one it starts
there okay what's the probability that
an infinite pass gets to do this node at
least once well what can the Internet
past or it can be here and it always has
to pick a random
outage so it will could pick this loop
for quite a while but at some point with
probability 1 it's going to get off this
note either going to take this or this
outage whenever this happens well then
you might get to this node or this note
and now player one I should say once the
objective to be fulfilled so player 1 is
always behaving so as we get so that we
can fulfill it okay so whether the token
comes here or here player 1 will choose
the edge that makes the objective Patrol
so if we want to get reach ability for
this node be here you want to get there
player one to make it sure this means
that we've probability 1 we will get to
this note so if we make if you ask reach
for this node it's going to be this node
will be in it because the probability of
reaching the skin here will be 1 and
what about this node what's the
probability of getting to this note well
so again we start here we might do a few
self loops but then at some point the
token will get off either this one or
this one and now they're both equally
likely actually the probability of
reaching this node is a half the
probability of reaching this note is a
half okay so player 1 cannot guarantee
that this no dia is rich with
probability 1 it cannot guarantee that
this one is rich's 431 so that's the
explanation of what it means that the
objective is satisfied with probability
1 and I have a few more examples
things happen good for it
yeah so if if I actually say this note
back here no D is the settee what is
reach what I am so so far so good sorry
now I'm going sorry this was a decision
version here of the problem now I'm
going to the winning set version so this
will be my second algorithmic question
and this is the one that's usually
studied introduced only the previous one
to get you familiar with the problem and
to make it easier to define this one
okay so the winning set computation this
is usually what they want they being the
people model checking they want to give
you a graph in the given objective but
they will not give you a start node but
instead they say find me oil start notes
that such that there is this objective
can be fulfilled so give me also on a
graph it means give me oil start notes
for which there is an infinite paths
that satisfies the objective so
basically you can think of it as doing
the decision version on every possible
node in the graph so for rich billion
team would simply be finding or notes
that can reach a vertex and T hope you
see it is if no vertex in T belongs to a
strongly connected component but then
there is no starting node that can visit
T infinitely often so then you will
return the empty set and otherwise you
return all nodes that reach an SEC this
you should say an SSC that contains a
dot of T because there might be multiple
such sec is that contain an oddity okay
end on mdps we have the corresponding
problem so again you find a find oil
start notes for which there's a strategy
for player one to ensure that the
objective can be satisfied with
probability 1 so just like before we
doing this decision problem on all nodes
and all the ones where the decision
problem said yes these are the ones that
we should return okay so now here assume
that I and this is usually called the
almost true of winning set or just
winning set it up here you can also call
it the winning set so for example here
if you say T is equal to this note ii
what is the winning set
so we said already before that if you
start from this node you can definitely
get here with probability 1 so the
answer this node will then have to be in
the winning set for this objective but
also if you're here player 1 has a
strategy to visit this guy infinitely
often just go here and then stay here
forever or if you're here as well well
if you already start here you can also
just hope forever okay so actually if
you make d to be the target sakti the
vinings that is V if you say B or C
these are our target sets these two
nodes the target set consists of these
two nodes well obviously be cannot be in
the winning set there's no way 40 to get
to POC and now what about Abby itself
that be itself of course is a novena set
you if you started your just stay here
and what about si si is not in the
winning set because from CEO cannoli go
here mistake you can only go here and a
now is actually also at the winning side
while because for a with probability 1
you will get either to B or C and if you
know actually wrong again is also not in
the winning set because you managed to
get here then you go over here and you
will not see this sorry for reach
ability sorry for reach ability it is in
the meaning set for a bushy it's not
intervening set sorry for readability if
you started here with probability 1 you
get either to pee or C and then you have
seen it once you don't need to do it
infinitely often for each ability sorry
and to see it was also the winning side
because if you start it already you have
seen it already but okay fine so there
was still the simple case the more
sophisticated cases if you only have be
if the target is only be what's
happening then well D will not get to it
see will not get to it what about a he
has only a probability have to getting
to be thus it's also not in the winning
set so only be its surface in the being
set okay okay good so that's what we
have seen so far we have seen two
algorithmic questions and four
objectives now I need to introduce a few
more objectives because it's still very
limited what you can express with these
objectives so
the there will be four more objectives I
need to introduce so the first one is
the conjunctive and the disjunctive
objectives now what a conjunctive
objectivism you have a list of
objectives now assume you want the
intersection of these objectives
remember that your objectives it's a set
of internet path and so this is the
intersection of these sets okay so for
example reach of t1 and reach of t2
would be all paths that have to reach a
note of t1 end of Tito weapon so it's
the intersection of the sets and you can
also do it disjunctive so then it's the
order of the objectives so for reach
ability it's actually very simple reach
of T 1 over root of T 2 it's an
unnecessary because you could have
immediately said reach of T 1 Union t2
okay so some of these combinations will
make sense some are redundant but I'm
introducing this because they're true
famous objectives there are being
objective in the street objective that
are used that are defined using
disjunctive and conjunctive objectives
so let me start with a street pair a
street pair a one pair street objective
is given two sets an LNA you two sets of
notes all of you and it asks hope u of l
or push you a few which you can also
rewrite to beauty of L implies few of
you so what this says is if you want to
have all paths in for the pass and if a
path has visited L infinity often that's
what picture says then it also must
visit you infinity off so if you think
of ls being a potentially dangerous
state but you know that the note and
Ella okay if afterwards you're visited a
note in you then what you want to is
it's okay to visit L infinity often but
if you you then must also guarantee that
you will get visited infinity of so then
you know every visit of L gets
compensated for by a visit to you this
is a generalization of both species
cooperation into the street objective is
now you not just given one such plu you
give them a whole bunch of them k of
them and now you have the end of this so
for all these pairs this condition this
one pair
street condition were sold okay and then
the do all of it is there are being
objective which you just flip everything
around you get the one pair up in this
[ __ ] of L and copy of you so the path
has to visit L infinity often and you
only finitely often and then you have
the or of the bond Robin that's the rub
being objective okay so these are really
well studied and well used okay good now
we got all the objectives now my very
last definition it will be I will
introduce a third algorithmic question
okay so we had already these two
algorithmic questions he comes to sue at
one and it's going to look very similar
to this disjunctive objective but it's
different for some in some settings at
least this is called a disjunctive
queries okay with my very last
definition sorry and the disjunctive
query is as follows assume you give them
carry objectives give me all the start
nodes such that there is a strategy that
satisfies one of the objectives with
probability 1 so not the or of the
objectives but one of the objectives and
here is an example that makes clear what
this means so look at this graph with
the start node again and let's say the
settee we have a little bit of three
objectives one is t1 the other one is T
to the other one is T 3 and now if you
have a dist disjunctive query you ask is
there a strategy for the player to
almost surely reach one of t1 or t2 or
t3 if you have a disjunctive objective
and then you ask a dust player 1 have a
strategy to reach either t1 or t2 or t3
I'm actually I'm actually means with
probability 1 okay so that's completely
trivial like for example if you start
here let's say then anything no matter
what the player 1 does he goes here
let's say that's better here here and
then he from here the random no pics one
of these things and then he again picks
one of them let's say this one and he
goes here and now with probability a
half ago here before Billy javi goes
back so if this past just runs it
can take different notes if it just runs
long enough and at some point one of
these things here will be taken you
don't care which one in a disjunctive
objective you don't care which of these
notes will be picked one of them will be
picked with probability 1 okay so you
know this set t1 t2 t3 will be visited
before build upon no matter what player
1 does if you however insist on data not
you're not ok with having one of the
sets we pay about the set we picked but
having one specific node we picked us
probably one okay then you have a
disjunctive Korean and player 1 has to
be a bit more careful so here in this
case for example if player 1 here always
takes the highest note and then from
here let's say always picks us this one
here the second note here then he can do
that he can take this path here forever
and at some point here we get to t2 so
with probably one he can get to t2 so
actually he can make sure that t2 gets
reached ok so the difference is here the
player cannot determine which know it
gets reached out of that tea out of t1
t2 t3 he just knows one of them gets
picked but here he can actually fix
which one gets picked that's a
distinction between the two ok so now we
are done so I've introduced graphs on
MVPs I have introduced all the
objectives that are going to talk about
and I've introduced the algorithmic
questions and there's some combinations
here that make sense another stone
meaning making sense mean a disjunctive
query on crafts is actually the same
thing as a disjunctive objective these
difference between queries and
objectives disjunctive curious and
objectives only happens on MVPs and so
on ok but now our vice is interesting
well so far people in model checking
have not had a fine-grain approach ok so
they only classified problems by all the
MP complete or Co MP complete or not or
other polynomial time ok so for example
there is a more complicated model which
are this game graphs and they are if you
do the Rabine object if it's NP complete
if you do the street objective its co MP
complete but it was known that both
Robin and street are polynomial on NDP's
and on graphs and so they were
considered equivalently hard and now
what we do is we look at it from the
fine grain lens if you say can we
separate them it turns out yes you can
get some interesting separations so we
can show first of all our model
separation so for some of these problems
and I'll explain which ones we can show
that they actually hard on MVP
stenograph meaning we can give an
algorithm that pits the lower bound that
we can get four MVPs and then you can
also show that sometimes an objective is
really easier than its dual objective so
especially we can show that street is
easier than wrapping post on graphs and
the MVPs and finally we can also show
that for all the problems we have here
disjunction is always harder than
conjunction sorry you take any of these
problems that I've listed and you do a
disjunctive version of the objective or
a conjunctive ovation and then the
disjunction is harder so specifically so
for separating MVPs two graphs we can
show even if you just take the simple
reach or beauty objectives and you use
disjunctive queries then on graphs we
have an algorithm the transcend time M
plus n times K so m is the number of HS
n is the number of vertices in decay is
the number of targets that you have ok
so remember is that assange disjunctive
queries over K different target sets ok
we get this why we get lower bounds on
MVPs which are larger than this K times
always almost quadratic in n or just
always quadratic quadratic in em and i
will show you both of these reductions I
mean we also have actually four MVPs we
have an algorithm that matches these
upper bounds at least four large enough
values of K so there's no hope that we
can make this lower bound stronger and
and then also for code believe we can
show our separation and well we can show
a separation for an objective in its to
land rover the thing you are very the
most proud of is the one that you can
show that extra street is easier than
rap in both on graphs so we given an
algorithm here so the green results are
all the new results this one he was from
our previous paper here we had given
for street to N squared + NK login and
we now have this lower bound on Robin
shows that this is harder and actually
we also have a new algorithm
generalizing the previous one on graphs
to md piece for street on mdps which
again is faster than the lower bounds we
can get for Robin okay and finally the
separating separation between
conjunction disjunction so for all these
problems here and we can show that
conjunction is easier than this junction
and now in this talk I've given you a
bunch of definitions but I will show the
proofs for the disjunction of
readability in graphs or mvps in MVPs
actually because you know it's easier
when you go to prove when you see what
these new models to concentrate on one
and show the proof for that okay so i'll
do i'll show you here I'll show you yeah
this one here this lower bounds here and
then I'll show you an algorithm which
shows that this is tied
okay so this would be a reduction from
try and reach detection you know
triangle detection and so we assume here
that there's no community real time
algorithm that runs in sub cubic time
that detects whether the note away that
the graph contains a triangle in this
will give you this spot here in the
reductions as follows so take your graph
to you and make four copies of the notes
insert HSS usual if there was an edge
from A to B in the original graph insert
HS here between all these layers into
the start node at the beginning oh and
then make a fifth copy okay but the fist
copy is well connected as follows these
all these notes you apply why not except
for the fourth copy which is a random
note and then it has an edge to this
target notes ok so the fourth the fifth
copy of the graph will be the targets at
TA and the targets at TB and the
targeted TC each target set consisted of
one note ok
now what's interesting so assume there
exists a triangle in this graph okay
let's just say you can go ibca then and
there is a strategy for player one to
make sure that this set TI here is
reached how well the player should just
follow the triangle all the time ok so
you when he's here at the start he goes
to the note that's on the triangle let's
say and then he follows the triangle
gets here now the random not might send
him back but if he does this infinitely
awesome that was probably one he will
get here so if there is a triangle then
and this node s here is in the almost
chovanec set on the other side assume
that s is an homage to opening set well
then look at the internet pass that gets
us there the that internet path must get
one exactly one of these things here in
with probability 1 into the again must
reach this thing here with probability 1
which means that lets say it reaches
this was probably month which means like
this note here must have been visited
infinitely often if it wasn't recently
infinitely often couldn't get there and
even more not only does this node has to
be visited infinity of none of the other
nodes can have been visited infinitely
often because if they were then there
would be unknown constant probability to
get here nonzero probability and then
the probability to get here would not be
1 so the corresponding node here was
visited infinitely often in none of the
others were visited infinitely often now
how it is possible this is only possible
if there was a triangle containing the
snow to be because if there's no
triangle then the half of the time you
have to go to another node at least half
of the time okay so actually there is a
triangle in the graph if and only if
player 1 has a strategy to visit exactly
one of these nodes with probability 1
from is which means s is in the witness
winning set for the disjunctive
reachability query
I said it again oh it's okay it's here
and now how large is this reduction
where we had n nodes we have as many
edges as in the original graph and K the
number of sets that we needed to end we
had n target sets each of constant eyes
so beta is the total size of the target
set so this shows that if you could
solve the disjunctive reachability query
in time k times notes to the two minus
epsilon then actually try and early
detection would be solved in time really
sub cubic just plug in this value of K
okay so this shows this lower bound and
since this problem for mdps okay and
since there's a problem can be solved on
graphs in n plus K and time the shows
that this problem is harder on mdp set
on graphs so this gives us a separation
between the models okay now we have also
reduction from orthogonal vectors that
gives this bound also we know vectors
you have two sets of T bit vectors
please login and each set has size n and
there's no sub quadratic algorithm to
decide whether there is a vector appear
vectors that's also organized okay so
here what we do is for each vector in
the first set we create a node for each
vector second side with radial node for
each dimension we create a node this
year will be random notes basis play one
note and now there is an edge from
Nodine player one in set one to accord
coordinate if this is set to one and
there is an edge over here if it's set
to zero if the corresponding coordinate
is set to zero okay so because this is 0
there is an edge to coordinate one and
because this is one dataset okay and
then again we have for all the guys in s
to all the vectors and s2 we have target
notes ok now the reduction is as follows
so assume they exist two orthogonal
vectors U and V then player 1 should
pick them meaning so when player one is
here let's say this node resection
orthogonal to to this
one so then when player one is here it
should pick obviously strategy going to
this note then this one here was sent
him to out could be multiple
coordinators just one to this one and
then when he said this note again he
always should pick this one he should
pick the vector V this is possible
because these two things are orthogonal
so there must be wherever there is a one
here so wherever the random note would
send him there must be a zero in the
corresponding coordinate meaning there
must be this edge so if they're two
orthogonal vectors then this is a clear
strategy that exists and then if you
place this forever the strategy that at
some point you will get here so yes what
if this one is just zeros if here one
guy is just all sure yes but then
already when you build the graph you
figure out that is orthogonal to
everything then you immediately done so
then already building this only takes
time linear in in the sets and in the
size of the graph so then in linear time
your fans at the query yeah that's
always with all the other reductions
also if it's a trivial answer you find
it by building the reduction in you're
done okay now the other case so soon
there exists a strategy and that is
winning okay so that from s you can
actually get to one of these nodes with
probability 1 okay let's say you can get
to this one here with probability 1 and
then look at the strategy what does
player 1 do in order to get here a
player 1 has to make officer makes
always the same to us here at s and then
makes always the same choice at the
coordinate in the middle vector ok so
the claim is so he pick some you here
and to pick some v here 5 picking an
outgoing edge he picks a note here and
by picking here an outgoing edge he
picks a note here so the claim is that
this no do that he picks you a note V
that you pics here that they are
actually was organized well biases so
since he can since he can get from here
to a note here okay this random note
will send him to one of the coordinates
and no matter which coordinate this note
was sent him they have was always the
possibility infinity often could you get
to the note you denote V infinitely
often so did let's say this was no do
this was not V that player 1 picked in
the strategy that's winning okay so
since he was able to get here infinitely
often this means that no matter which
coordinate vector here coordinate note
play the random node would send him to
there was always the possibility of
getting to this node here infinitely
often this means that no matter where
the ones were here so this guy can only
send him out if there is a one in the
coordinate he can only send him to
coordinate if there was the one here so
no matter which one like for example for
this one he could send him to all three
but no matter which one he sent him to
there was always for him the possibility
to get to the corresponding vinod which
means they must have always been an edge
to the vm node which by our definitions
of the edges means there must have been
a zero so everywhere where there is a
one here there must have been a zero
here so for this guy is not orthogonal
but this guy's orthogonal to this one
and so he has only one outage but if
they had been another coordinate with an
outage here let's say with the one and
there was always a possibility to get
here that means there must have been an
edge here which means the master BR 0 on
this different on this coordinate for
this node up there because there was
this edge here so the from the fact that
there is an edge we can deduce that
wherever there is a 1 here there is a 0
here which means that these two vectors
are orthogonal
you know the size of this reduction
again it uses an end nodes and in logan
edges and so the same argument is before
then shows that if you could choose
solve this faster then it is top cubic
in the sub quadratic in the number of
edges or k times the number of HS to the
power minus epsilon then you would so if
what's all connectors faster so this
gives you the lower bound a relative to
the number of HS five minutes left that
started a little late yes okay good so
now let me quickly tell you about the
algorithm for disjunctive reach ability
in MVP so this is the upper bound that
shows that this lower bounds are type at
least for larger last values of K now I
have to introduce a notion of a random
attractor a random attractor is defined
algorithmically as follows you give them
some set you of nodes which you said a
equals you initialize it with the set
you and so as long as you edit note to a
the last iteration you keep on
performing the situation you add to a or
player 1 vertices where all the outer
edges go into a ok or so let's say if
you had this and you also add to a all
random vertices that have at least one
out edge into a ok so like here if this
was you say to you initially then this
one does not have all its outer just
going into you you can't edit it but
this one has at least one edge going
into you so you can add it to a and now
you have added something to end the last
iteration so you continue so now for
this node all its outer edges go into a
so now you would at this node and also
this one now has one it's going into a
so this one and that's it you cannot add
any more nodes so this would have been
the random attractor of you and what
does the random attract I should capture
will all vertices that are in the random
attractor have a positive probability to
reach you no matter what player one does
so the random a tractor or this note
will play one with at least constant
probability table getting too meaning he
cannot get to the good set so this will
be the bad guys so you know that you for
some
bed set then these are the ones where
player 1 will not be able to get to the
good set because this concert
probability will get to the bed set so
you cannot with probability 1 get to the
good set okay so this is the random a
tractor now here's a very simple NM
algorithm or visibility in mdps and
which works as follows it's also called
almost to reach ability so ASR how much
storage ability which works as follows
and so you have your safety in first you
do just regular graph readability so
ignoring the type of the nodes where
they play one random you just reach
ability and this gives you some set s s
will be an over estimate of the winning
set there will be guys in there who will
not then finally be in the winning set
but at least they are an overestimate so
you know everybody who is not in s they
are really bad they will definitely not
be in the winning set because they don't
even have a pass to G to use where you
want to get to ok so now you can take V
minus s out but not just three minus s
you can take out the whole the whole
random attractively minus s so everybody
every note that has might get pulled
into V minus s with nonzero probability
you take them all out and then you
repeat you said V the PV minus a and you
repeat until there is nobody no such
note left until a is empty and if a is
empty then you know V minus s must also
have been empty so everybody can at
least do the graph reach ability in T
and then there's a Sun God sophisticated
proof they chose that actually in this
set in this case s whatever left and in
s is actually good set is the winning
set so as long as every note can
actually reach tea and issue you have
taken out all its for the bad ones you
have taken out all the random attractor
then you can prove it's not obvious ok
then you can prove that this is actually
the winning set ok so this algorithm was
known and actually I had krishnendu had
improved it to em to the 1.5 and I have
been improved with condition and 0 to N
squared and this algorithm and now if
you want to do disjunctive eligibility
remember that's what we're working on
disjunctive for each ability for K
targets you could just run this K times
and get this running time
however we came to it better and we can
do it I skip this example okay let's
just shows how the sink but and I need
my very last definition which is also a
good problem to know actually because
again they don't know linear time
algorithm and this year is very similar
to strongly connected components so it's
called maximal nth component
decomposition okay and there's a
corresponding thing to strongly
connected components in graphs and the
fastest algorithm to have such a thing
to compute suggesting is the minimum of
N squared + m to the 1.5 so again open
here what's the real answer and there's
no lower bound either for this problem
so the definitions for as follows an end
component you is a set of vertices such
that the graph induced by you is
strongly connected and no random vertex
has an outgoing edge to a vertex in V
minus u so for example if you had
something like this ok so this would be
a nice nth component ok there could be
let's say like this still this year's a
nice n component but if this fellow here
has an H now here then this is no longer
named component right because there is a
red this random node has an outgoing
edge so now it just breaks up into
individual notes so this graph has no
end component and now what we want to
compute is the maximal nth component
decomposition which for a graph finds
all the end components order set vice
maximal set inclusion buys maximal end
components just like the strongly
connected components of the maximal
strongly connected pieces so you want to
find the maximal end component and you
want to make sure and individual notes
like here you would just return all
individual notes so and the nice
observation that we had was as follows
and either all vertices assume you have
computed for your graph this maximal and
component decomposition then either all
vertices belong of a maximal end
component belong to the winning set or
not so within a maximal end component
it's all or none in the winning set and
thus this gives rise to the idea you
we actually contract or these end
components to just one note and then
whatever so to sin decision for the node
in the contractor graph will be the
decision for all the guys in the inside
and the nice thing is if there are no
Maxima in component if you contract them
then now you can show that there is no
nontrivial nth component a trivial n
component is a bundled with a self loop
player one bond out with a self loop so
there will be no nontrivial in component
and now we had this observation that if
the MVP contains no nontrivial n
component then actually just one
iteration of these previous algorithm
suffices to find a winning set ok and
here you have to modify the proof of the
previous algorithm to prove this ok so
this gives us this very simple final
algorithm you compute the maxima in
component decomposition you contract all
the maxima in components that you found
and now for each of your target sets you
run one iteration of the previous
algorithm which means you'll find the
set s that can reach TI you take out its
random attractor there's some slight
modification which doesn't affect the
running time and then V minus a is the
winning set for this target and so we
since your dish disjunctive disjunctive
you will take the union of all these
winning sets and then in the end of
course you have to undo the contraction
to output the final winning set and so
this algorithm has just running time k
times m right because this is just
linear time or the step co-leading time
k times M plus the time for the make
decomposition which I told you was n
squared or m to the 1.5 and so this
upper bound here actually matches the
lower bound which you the previous lower
bounds you could also rewrite as follows
and so for K that is at least square
root M the upper bound and the lower
bound matches because then the make does
not dominate the running time the time
to computer make does not dominate or
enter okay so now what are the open
problems well it turns out that for all
these problems here the reach ability in
md piece that i just talked about or
computing the mac decomposition or the
street problem in for the street problem
that's even true in graphs there is no
linear time algorithm in there are no
conditional lower bounds so it's wide
open bodies
and say yeah this upper bounds are like
this and then also the Robin on MVP
still has a gap so we have shown this
lower bound but we have an upper bound
that's only like this different
algorithm for this so there's also gap
and then for some of this lower bounds
we actually need the combinatorial
assumption like four triangle detection
the assumptions there is no
combinatorial algorithm for orthogonal
vectors there's no component at oriole
algorithm for that and what if you a
suit but if you remove this assumption
this means that now algorithm is fast
matrix multiplications are allowed but
there is no algorithm using any trick so
fascinated Rick's multiplication to give
a fast they would give a fast algorithm
okay all the algorithms that are known a
combinatorial so could there be fast
algorithms using some ideas from fast
nitrix publication thank you yeah you
sure the bail amount of K times n square
so that won't even k is linnea so do you
know anything when you take no also good
open question yes can these reductions
be adapted for example
yes yes well actually like it gets into
all good conferences so this one you are
only going to submit now to leaks but
the previous paper where we have this
improved algorithm for Street got into
leaks as well so logic in computer
science conference yeah they did a very
interested yeah we have mastered graph
super algis have used no that's why it's
important to get down to Linnea yes
you're trying to eventually push it down
to you yes so for these problems at
least yes but yes they do have massive
graphs and getting it down from a n
square to end with the huge and also
usually their grass the extra sparse so
very often ms order in so yes they
definitely interested especially they
had not heard of fine growing complexity
at all so it's definitely interesting
but so that's why I wanted to tell you
about these problems there is actually
community that cares about it yeah so
beyond the MVPs there's a concept of a
stochastic game where you had player 1
player 2 who is the adversary player 1
and also random notes and you could
raise all these questions for stochastic
games yes so these actually this so i
looked at least at the restricted
version may I have player 1 and player 2
but no random notes so so this game
graphs and so therefore pushy for
example we also have an N squared
algorithm and but some of the other
problems already like that is chunked
irritability already NP complete so very
soon tell you get to NP completeness but
they're always a very interesting open
programs like the parody games whether
you can get a sub explanation time I
gross in there yes but there's a whole
bunch there's another yeah these are the
more complicated graph models that I
didn't even talk about here
more questions it's not that same party
ok